Hey, Georgia.
Georgia.
>> Hey Anthony.
Sorry about that, what's up?
>> So, I collected some data
about project compos, but
I want to format it in a way
that doesn't look so boring.
>> Well, data analysis not only
analyze and extract data, but
they also create data visualizations.
What data visualization?
A data visualization is
a representation of data.
So like charts, maps or graphs.
Okay so I've seen that everywhere.
I didn't realize they were also
called data visualizations.
>> Yeah.
There's a lot of ways you can
create data visualizations but
a couple libraries are D3 js or
temple js.
They both use HTML and CSS.
>> Like frontend programmers.
>> Exactly, let me show you an example.
So as you can see,
when I hover over this data point
it shows me more information.
>> That is cool, I think I'll try using
Dimple for my project compass data.
>> Awesome.
>> Definitely check out
the documentation if you need help.
>> Thanks, Georgia.